hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast connect across a thousands of
expertly curated genomics datasets using
kiya genes immunology focused disease
land database presented by dr. Lucy
Williams a senior bio informatics
scientist at kiya Jen I'm dr. Susie
Valdes of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by kiya Jen for more
information about our sponsor visit them
at wwk agency um before we begin I'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation just click on that ask
a question box to let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credit just click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining your credits
please join me now in welcoming our
presenter dr. Lucy Williams I will now
turn the presentation over to her
welcome dr. Williams
so thank you thank you for giving me the
opportunity to describe the immunology
content of our disease land database and
also I just kind of wanted to briefly
introduce myself as you said I am by
informatician with kaigan and I'll make
sauce and Cary North Carolina and major
aspect of that role in customer
relations is in terms of software
development is to really advocate for
the customer and in a huge part is to
address the everyday challenges that are
faced in genomics and as well as to
train customers on what the software has
to offer in terms of overcoming those
challenges
for today's agenda what I'm going to do
is to basically describe the land
database and the the software solution
itself the lands framework and then I'll
go into an overview specifically of what
immunology content is in that database
and then we will a focus look at some
example use cases and then finally we'll
end with just some summary
so again to start off what will first do
is we'll talk about what the database is
and then we'll talk about what the
software solution or the lands of
framework is and how that's designed to
enable the the scientists to overcome
those everyday challenges in your
research
so basically what the situation is and
what we heard from the customers is that
out there exists in the public space
genomic data sets and these data sets
are really underutilized in terms of
their value because to take advantage of
that existing knowledge we find that you
also oftentimes have to basically
reinvent the wheel and what we mean by
that is the challenge is that it's
tedious and it's resource intensive to
download these genomic data sets develop
the analysis pipelines to be able to
visualize that data and then finally you
have to have a place to store all of
that data across thousands of
disease-focused studies so what if a you
know existed a database that already had
all of that data pre analyzed and loaded
into it and that was integrated with an
easy-to software solution to allow both
the in fermentations as well as the
bench scientists to quickly access that
data so that's essentially what the LANs
framework solution addresses and the
impacts in is to be able to allow
scientists to empower their research
quickly identifying the high quality
data sets that are value to them and for
the in fermentations to really focus
their attention on the the advanced
pipeline development so let you know the
software do the basics and enable you to
get the data out and to really expand
upon that data analytics
essential feature of building that data
into the land is consistency of course
standardization as well as quality
control and so what I'm showing here is
basically the pipeline's that we use to
actually take those genomic data sets
and to build them to our lands database
basically the overview is that we start
with data retrieval and that's defined
by basically going to either public
projects new projects or for example
private data so for example a customer's
data or your data and we basically you
know QC those those data and we download
the raw data as well as the sample and
project level metadata that's associated
with those public projects then there's
a two phase curation process both the
metadata curation which is handled by
scripting out the sample and project
level details as well as hand curation
of the studies and two controlled
vocabulary and then there's a data
processing segment where we are taking
the raw files we're extracting the
signals we're applying standard
normalizations in sample level QC and
then we're pulling that all together at
the next phase where the curators or the
expert level biologists are enabling the
implementations and existing basically
stating these are the models based on
these projects that need to be defined
and then what happens in the next phase
is we actually take those data and we
generate and print reports and finally
there's a post QC analysis which happens
at multiple levels from the sample level
KCl is where we can hand go into the
project and pull from other literature
that exists to look at things like you
know how consistent is this expression
change based on what we know from other
literature and then finally all those
data will basically go into that Landis
so both the
I'll make data as well as the the
metadata so then what is this database
and what actual entry mark and what's
the solution that we're providing so in
addition to actually processing the data
and processing the curated metadata
solution here again has to do with some
key features related to for example
accessing the data as well as the data
footprint so for example we can we have
the ability to store high-volume data so
bio Bank scale data with very quick
within second level accessing all of
that data and then secondarily the data
footprint of course is is is a major
problem when you're dealing with
thousands upon thousands of genomic data
sets and then in the substitution lands
are actually delivered via the cloud so
we're able to from the customers site
have a very small data footprint in
addition ada integration is a key
feature of alayan framework and what
that enables you to do is to basically
browse across the different projects so
for example if you wanted to look across
multiple projects that were all under
the same disease category do that or
multiple studies but also data
integration in terms of the types of
data so oftentimes when you have a
biological question for example you
would want to look at how the expression
level of a gene that correlate with
cover status and so we can integrate
both across studies as well as across
data types and then finally we have
powerful interact interactive software
solutions so in this screenshot what
you're seeing is many different types of
visualizations that you can quickly
generate and interact with in the land
framework so for example heat maps
interactive volcano plots for single
petal data we can we can do clustering
we have interactive genome browsers and
then for every shark that's in the land
our Associated sample level details so
for example you can drill out into the
worm showing here on the bottom right
hand corner of the slide you can drill
down to the sample level or Meishan
which really empowers you to be able to
interpret that data so do I believe the
data that's in there do I want to for
example regroup that data and build new
comparisons and etc so these
specifically key features of both the
land
firk the database as well as the way
that the database is interacting with
the software the client based software
in addition though for implementations
we do offer the ability to dump data out
through API features
okay so I've gone over basically the the
framework at a high level and so now
we'll get specifically into what
immunology content exists in the
database
so for the most part our immunology
content is Provost what that means is
that we've curated in studies
specifically from public sources such as
geo as a array express and these studies
are grouped based on the organism that
the study was performed in so human or
mouse rat we can broadly do other genome
references as well so cat or dog and the
idea is is that the wave the individual
would interact with those data is that
it would be organized on whether the
study was performed in human or mouse or
rat and then across those different
organism based subsets within that that
you would have different data types so
for human you might have data types of
microwave or peak methylation
methylation see core micro RNA which
could all be accessed within the same
land database and then the only sort of
exception to that would be that we can
handle the single-cell RNA seek but in
order to be able to distinguish between
the bulk and the single-cell RNA seek we
need to be able to help that single-cell
data into separate land interfaces and
so that would be housed into for example
the single-cell human or the single-cell
Mouse individual lands and then broken
down by the type whether it's um iron on
you might based
so when you access the the immunology
content you are getting a subscription
to you the data content and so if we
look at the graph here you can see that
broken down by whether it's here or m/l
study and the year basically 2016 2017
or 2018 we can look at the growth of the
content in terms of sample number over
time and then we can see that this is
broken down based on those therapeutic
areas and so for example we can see that
you know there is a major emphasis
recently to almost double for example
the therapeutic area of immunology or
immuno modulators within the land
databases likewise I recently from 2017
to 2018 there is a huge emphasis on
building in tables under the category
psychiatry and again this is a data
subscription and these increases over
time are built upon stemmer request
and then looking at the the same graph
but now looking at the samples broken
down by the source instead of the
therapeutic area we can we can see where
if this sample came from skin for
example we've basically doubled that
over time or a huge emphasis a lot of
content in the land is humid effect
system and again it increases
significantly over the years and we're
upwards of over a hundred and twenty
thousand different samples now at 2018
and so again emphasizing the concept
that this is a data subscription and in
addition to content we increased the
types of data which are built into the
land generally upon customer request
depended upon again what kinds of
queries are our customers interested in
the primary data type is has long been
microarray although we are increasing
course they are na seek and we're
building in new data types such as the
micro RNA samples which are a new data
type in the human disease database and
so what I'm showing here is in these
numbers is the total number of projects
that are in each database and then
within parentheses are the ones that
were added within this year again just
to emphasize the the contact data
subscription and the fact that these
databases are increasing continually
based on customer driven requests
you
and so one of the data types that I
showed in the previous slide is a
comparisons and so innocent to loading
in the expression level for example
based on normalized expression level
we're also having the curators in base
our biome for magicians to build those
inferences or build what we call the
Commission's so for example if we have a
single project that project maintain
samples that are of normal or diseased
individuals and then we could have
untreated or aided from both of those
different normal or diseased individuals
and so the comparisons are based on the
the meta data and extracting relevant
information out of of that metadata bill
what kinds of inferences are what kinds
of questions we we want to explore and
then loading in the default changes for
example in plant in addition to the
normalized expression values
and here's an example of actually her
acting with the software to view the
comparisons so if I were for example
interested in the disease of psoriasis I
could basically filter down to samples
that were from a disease state of
psoriasis and then I could realize all
of the different inferences or
comparisons that are in the land for
that difference that disease and so
example here we're looking where the
samples were maps to psoriasis um on the
y-axis and the number of comparisons on
the x-axis and then these are
color-coded based on the type of
comparison that was performed and so
here you can see that in the database we
have different types based on that
metadata so for example in the case of
is type 1 versus cell type 2 comparison
we may have had that in the original
study they Amand for example an
inflammatory inflammatory cell versus a
naive cell and that would fall into a
cell type 1 versus cell type 2
comparison or they could have done a
disease versus normal comparison to to
examine for example skin samples from a
control individual and an individual
with psoriasis and then oftentimes some
of the high there's some high interest
in these responder versus non responder
studies and and so for example that's
what I'm showing here we could highlight
those interactively from the histogram
and we can look at the exact comparisons
and view all the metadata so we can look
and we can see here that we have the
ability to look at comparisons for
response versus no response and in this
case we have a time course we also will
test from the same study and samples
were taken at baseline two weeks and
four weeks so this is the type of data
that you can visualize and see in the
land
me a type of inferences that the
metadata is enabling
okay and so now let's say we take this
example and we want to highlight those
comparisons we actually browse the
database
we can do that we can basically take
those comparison IDs and we can search
that vated database and are actively
using these visualization tools and we
can bring back visualizations such as
for example the side by side volcano
plots where now we can look at the
response versus no response comparisons
across the different time points we can
interactively highlight data points of
interest and we can see so if we have a
potential genes that what you think is
interesting at baseline how did it spawn
as a four week time point so now again
we're able to interactively view across
the different comparisons and really
we're building off of that data gradient
concept
so based on those comparisons we can
follow that the metadata that can is the
controlled vocabulary introduced by the
curators this is a central aspect of the
land and so what I basically mean by
that for example we were using psoriasis
to sample and so if we were interested
in diseases that we might take samples
from skin this would fall into for
example the skin and connective tissue
diseases and so what we do is we define
the samples based on their disease state
such as psoriasis or dermatitis and
those would ultimately get grooved into
land into broader categories such as the
skin and connective tissue or for
example allergy so by building these
controlled vocabularies we are able to
take those you know millions of samples
and organize them into and in a way
that's easy to browse in and pick
through all of those different samples
based on that metadata
so that metadata is actually organized
into the land and visible to the user in
a table format and so for example if we
look and see that we have sample IDs we
can define the subject that the sample
came from that broader disease category
the disease state and then for example
in some cases if the in addition to the
disease state if there's a stage or
example as I'm highlighting here
screenshot we can visualize what the
stage is so we have onset is the is the
sample taken from an active disease
stage or is it in remission and then
there's also the concept of the tissue
category in addition to the disease
itself we also highlight whether or not
the initial study indicated a particular
cell type that the samples were taken
from and then from the cell type we can
build into that based on the tissue so
for example if we were specifically
interested in understanding long
pathology we may want to specifically
look at alveolar macrophages and we may
so we would may compare that to your
example epithelial cells that would
actually end up being a cell type 2 cell
type comparison and we could kind of
filter that down in the land based on
the broader category of tissue and even
broader Bay on something like
respiratory tract and that would help us
to define from a broader tissue category
in addition to disease how to find the
name of the land that we're interested
in
so taking that as an example what we can
see is if we were to regroup all the
data in the land based on the idea of
this pencil type so in this case we're
looking at cape cell type so we were
doing a case versus control study the
cell type as a case would have been
reported and we can basically filter in
the land down to the specific cell type
of interest and you can see that taken
from the original metadata that's been
hand curated in we can get fairly
defined we can spot for example many
different types of immune cells that may
be of interest
and so again I'm just kind of taking
that into how it works into the actual
software basically that control
vocabulary is loaded in with the actual
data and it's organized into these views
for example here in the middle of your
screenshot you're looking at the chart
view which is interactive and so we can
define based on the y-axis all of the
samples and the DC date that was was
identified from the original project and
then the color coding test the tissue
category that the sample came from and
so we wanted to typically hone in on for
example psoriasis we could we could and
we could find out just how many
psoriasis samples there are so there's
over or just under 12,000 and we could
select specifically the skin samples
and again the metadata is organized into
higher arteries so in addition to be
able to browse it in the land we can use
it to fill it down the database and so
that's what I'm showing here on the Left
labeled by the number two if I wanted to
specifically identified dermatology
samples I could use a therapeutic area
filter to check box just the dermatology
samples
and so again we could do the filters we
could select psoriasis and then we could
interactively select from the histogram
which is what I'm showing here with my
mouse
I turned the siree samples from skin
pink and and when I do that I can
interact with the metadata it was a
sample the project and even the clinical
details level and we can get exportable
tables about those individual samples or
that project and then another aspect of
the land is the ability to build off of
not just the previous studies that we're
curating in but to create new studies by
creating ampuls outs and then running
analytics in the land and so that's what
I'm showing here so if we wanted to get
a light different samples in this chart
and we could say create sample set and
we could build our own comparisons
interactive in the land framework
and then again just kind of going off of
this concept of all of that meta de the
other thing that you might frequently
want to do is to know if a project has
what data types so from the previous
screen I could just do two clicks
basically to answer that question so I
could go from the previous screen where
the y-axis was defined by cell type or
these days and what I could do is I
could regroup now use the project name
and I could get the actual exception ID
and then I could quickly recolor the
samples based on whether or not I have
RNA seek data for that sample and then I
can interactively grab just the samples
that rna-seq is a data type they also
fall into my other calories of interest
so just kind of going back to this
quantum data integration and what data
exists again the data is organized based
on whether it's humans are rat and then
but within those lands the data type are
all covered including micro RNA seek
methylation array etc except for when
we're looking at single cell data and
those lands are separated out based on
boxset the single cell data is bulky
because we're looking at individual
cells and we need specialized views to
view that data
so just to look at the diseased land
content specifically from single-cell
RNA seat
we can see basically that again it's
grouped by human or mouth and then we
have it organized based on whether it's
um I or non um I based and so in this
screenshot what you can see is that we
have a the the um I based samples on the
left and yellow and blue and then non
unit you my base samples in red and
green on the right and what I wanted to
size here is in addition to the numbers
in terms of the cell counts as well as
the types of cells the cell types that
are in each land the fact that we are
covering different library strategies
within the land so we're able to within
the land have the different platforms
and incomparable across those data
and so kind of focusing in on kinds of
cell types we're looking at for example
we can see that in the mouse we have a
real emphasis on the Hamada Postum and
in those cell types and just kind of
taking the the example from the mouse
land this pie chart that I'm showing on
the bottom right is really emphasizing
the types of cells that are coming in
from the lab for the excel lineage so
we're looking at the monocytes the
b-cells and so we're really able to
compare across the individual cell types
now and to answer biology questions
about you know what how what's my marker
gene expression like in this particular
cell type and again you can download
that data so the single cell lands
because of the data processing we've
already processed the data we've
controlled everything and now you're
able to quickly just download out the
the reports from that and again kind of
build off of the fact that we've done
early work for you and now you can
enable yourself to basically move into
the questions that you want to address
with this in there and the analysis but
the advanced analysis pipelines
okay so now I just wanted to just get a
few screenshots in the example use cases
for how you might use the the data
that's in the land
and again just re-emphasizing the
concept here is to basically empower
yourself to you address those important
ology questions with some easy-to-use
software
so as an example let's say that I'm
interested again in those psoriasis
samples so we can look across the the
database and we can define how many
total samples there are psoriasis so
there are a little under 2,000 samples
from human subjects and how many total
comparisons were performed so in this
case we have a hundred and twenty-seven
comparisons and those are broken down
based on cell type comparisons disease
versus normal or again the responder
versus non responder and the treatment
versus control so let's say we had a
question what we wanted to know you know
what's differential expression
signatures for psoriasis samples
you wanted to specifically sort of hone
in on maybe you know cell type or the
different you know the different types
of receive of comparisons so maybe a
disease versus normal compression but in
this case for example we could
specifically look at whether if we were
interested for example in dendritic
cells we could filter down directly to
the comparisons that will sit to
introduce cells and we could look for
example at inflammatory to genetic cells
specifically in skin if we wanted to
select that particular comparison
but in this case let's say that what
we're interested in is we're interested
in the denying differentially expressed
genes that are between weasels is not on
regional sir psoriatic skin samples so
in this case what we'll do is we're
filtering down all the fat examples into
examples where both the case and the
control were psoriatic individuals with
sore psoriasis and we're going to then
look at sample pathology where the
pathology was defined as we know versus
non regional
can quickly do that by a keyword search
we can look at a comparison and we can
say what was the contrast applied and we
can essentially say for sample pathology
show me everything that exists for
regional versus non regional which is
what's going on the left so it's a
really a keyword search based filter and
then basically on the chart under the
tissue category of skin and pink I've
highlighted those comparisons that were
a disease versus normal and we can see
that got 16 comparisons specifically
from microarray studies so we're
excluding out the RNA seek studies at
this point we're specifically looking at
studies that were performed in
microarray studies and what we can
immediately do once we've made the
selection is on the bottom left and say
browse selected comparisons and we can
immediately query the database
so what that's going to do is it's going
to pull up for example a tape or we're
able to see all the comparison IDs and
the projects that come from that came
from those comparisons and then we can
identify that significant gene list and
we can see the genes that were
significant across basically each
individual comparison so we can look at
is AG significant and you know test one
versus test seven or leave the
significant counts column in this table
to say of sixteen studies was my gene of
interest significantly up regulated all
sixteen studies so this is the type of
quick query that we can do to identify a
list of genes where synthesis that they
are upregulated across all sixteen
studies providing robust evidence that
for example those genes may be
signatures of regional versus non
regional psoriasis
and then from there what we might want
to do is I want to sort of explore based
on that gene signature what other
diseases may exhibit a similar pattern
and so what we can do is we can take the
database and we can query it
specifically for the disease versus
normal comparisons and we can pull back
the full change information for our gene
list and we can build these interactive
heat maps where we can get the
differential expression for our genes of
interest code it as upregulated or
downregulated red versus green and then
on the bottom we have the color bars
which can define what is the disease
category or what was the sample source
and so here we can see from the list of
genes that I found that was a consensus
across the 16 different comparison sets
we can see that to some degree there is
a similar gene signature between
psoriasis and Kalama Tauri bowel disease
in addition oftentimes we might want to
understand if this is a gene signature
some of these genes could potentially be
used as predictive biomarkers and we
might want to know for example is that
only the case if I had skin samples or
is it possible that this could be a
predictive biomarker in a disease versus
normal comparison so for example a
control individual versus someone with
psoriasis and could we measure these
markers and identify differential
expression and other tissue types so for
example peripheral blood and so here
again we've taken the same heat map from
the previous screenshot and I've applied
some filters to narrow down the disease
category to specifically basically the
skin and connective tissue diseases or
specifically psoriasis and I've
regrouped the data according to the
sample source so now we can look at the
color bars and we identify again if
we're looking at skin psoriasis samples
from skin and a disease versus normal
comparison that we do have the similar
patterns of regulation and down
regulation across the database but in
this case for example if we hone in on
the peripheral blood samples we see that
that pattern is not displayed so in this
case will not be able to use peripheral
blood as a way to measure the expression
changes in this case versus control
comparison we wouldn't need skin samples
and finally the other thing I wanted to
show is the interactive nature of the
the the interface and so conceived it
basically at the top of the heat map
there is one Square which is purple and
that's because in the software I can
interactively click on individual
squares and I can pull up in the details
pane on the bottom right and we can see
the box plots where we're actually able
to see the sample level information and
the civic comparisons in this case where
we are looking at that particular gene
and we can see the psoriasis versus
normal control comparison and look at
the individual samples and look for
example the metadata information it was
supplied from that comparison in the
interactive table under the metadata
information in this center of the screen
and then finally kind of building off of
the fact that we have the different
types of data loaded into the land we
may want to take the same gene immature
I mean when you want to ask so how do
those genes respond to different
treatments so in this case I've applied
an additional term into my data or now
I'm looking at two different subject
level treatments for two different drugs
and I'm comparing the skin samples
versus the the PBMC samples and we can
see that to some degree some of these
genes which are normally up regulated
and the regional versus non lethal
comparison are down regulated upon
subject training and we can identify
perhaps variability and the
responsiveness across the different
studies and start to perhaps credential
the types of biomarkers which may be
predictive of responses
okay and then so basically what I've
shown now is how we interact with the
software and we would be taking a full
gene list but also sometimes we might
have identified a particular regulator
within a pathway a particular gene
basically that we really wanted to
extensively credential and so what we
could do is we could specifically query
the database for that particular gene so
I'm looking at this s 189 and basically
I'm looking across the database at every
single data set that exists every single
comparison and I've reorganized those
comparisons by regrouping data on the
y-axis according to the L type and so
now we can see that if we were to
interactively
basically select from this bubble pot
which is basically showing sigit
interactions by showing a full change
basically on the x-axis and then the
size of these bubbles in the plot
defining the significance level we can
basically interact with that so I've
highlighted the the samples or the
comparisons I'm sorry in the purple box
and now we can see in the details pane
we can look at basically these DC cells
and we can look at the inflammatory
populations that are known to exist
within the skin samples we can identify
that this gene does in this study it was
up regulated in inflammatory disease so
again we hold off of all the data in the
land to continue to understand are the
results dating from our queries
so I just quickly then went through some
some focused use cases specifically for
psoriasis in so far I've mostly focused
on you know the expression data that we
have in the land before I hand I just
wanted to go through one final data type
emphasizing again the integration of the
different data types the other type of
content that we actually have curated
into the land is the Association studies
from Jia studies and and in those lands
for example we have over 5,000 different
phenotypes or Association results
related to over 5,000 different
phenotypes and this is a result in that
case is that the the variant level or
for example the snip level and each one
of those variants is going to get
annotated from a number of different
public databases and so as an example if
we wanted to sort of carry over from the
disease land immunology content and
really look at for example now at gos
studies what sort of content exists
related to immune ology we can see now
that in addition to the previous
different sets that I mentioned we have
you know over a hundred and ninety seven
different immunology related studies
over seven hundred sixty-two of those
which involve cancer or related measures
so we're not just looking at disease
were also looking at phenotypes drug and
treatment responses over six hundred and
specifically for autoimmune diseases
three hundred and fifty eight different
studies have been curated into the land
and for the genetics lands it's
important to have data consistency and
standardization so in these lands you
can browse across the different studies
at the same time based on the fact that
we have performed allele standardization
and so you're really able to explore and
kind of filter data from those
association hits based on the fact that
you can query across different studies
at the same time
Oh an example of how you might use this
database is let's say I was going to
continue I'm exploring the convey the
type of psoriasis we can see that we can
actually directly again filter based on
the metadata so we could filter and we
can look at studies which looked at just
you know higher level of psoriasis we
could pick that out or we could even get
more specific and we can look at the
Association of psoriasis and for example
Crohn's disease and basically what you
would get out is once you do the
phenotype search you would get tables
for example which would list individual
variants the the strength of the
Association based on p-value defect size
and other metadata which was pulled from
the original studies and then if that
particular variant is annexed to a gene
you would also get the gene name
information so this would be another way
that you could potentially credential
your gene list by not just looking at
different gene expression studies but
also by pulling in paracin across jiya
studies as well
and and so from there I'll just I'll
finish all again say thank you for
allowing me the time to basically
summarize the immunology content in our
disease line database and explain how
you can use that to enable your research
and then I just wanted to mention that
if you are interested in following up
with this I'm happy to chat you can
contact anyone in our omix office
customer relations group by emailing
through support oh my soft calm and if
you want to look at other cus you stay
psa's or just basically other tools that
might be in the software you can
actually go to these websites for equals
the video Holmes will show you other
example cases taken from disease land
that we've pre-recorded
with that I will end
thank you dr. Williams for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the Q&A portion of our webinar and
we'll address them as most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question drop-down box located on the
far left of your audio presentation and
type the questions into the box that
appear on the screen click the send
button our speaker will follow up with
questions via email so let's get started
our first question dr. Williams is if
I'm interested in a specific disease how
can I find out if disease land covers
that focused area
right so easiest way to basically
contact omics off support and we could
we could basically query the database
and give you a report back of you know
how many studies might cover that
disease area and then on key pages
websites that we've provided we actually
would put you know information about the
disease the diseases and the broader
categories based on the coverage that's
in the land and then I guess that segues
into the concept of if it doesn't exist
this is a data subscription so we're
happy to build data into the land based
on custom rest and if you already have
data we can definitely build a basically
the framework with your data content
basically may have it lands for for our
customers and then finally once you have
a subscription to the data you can
actually download the data and compare
against other public resources that
might be available so if we don't have
it in the land you could start now load
the data analyze it yourself and then
compare it against data that you could
pull out of our land as well
thank you for that information and what
methods are used to process the data
right so we're emphasizing the fact that
we're basically building the data into
them continuously so we're using
normalization methods that allow us to
normalize the data as it comes in and
basically do project level normalization
and then basically we're comparing
standards for full length realization
and then we're again we're applying
different levels we see both from the
processing pipelines as well as
basically and QC the data as well so a
number of different standards are
applied and again visualizing our wiki
pages will give all the dells behind
that
thank you and dr. Williams this next
question is a two-part question is there
a web-based application of a browser or
do I need to download software that's
the first part and similarly if I wanted
to compare my own beta against land
datasets can we do that
right so so this is basically the full
on my soft product line and what we have
to offer so in addition to the GUI
interface which I've showed here in my
screenshots we're that you're basically
getting a client software that you're
actually loading onto your own computer
we also do have a web-based browser
interface and then of course we have the
programmatic interface which I mentioned
previously so we have basically also
different ways that you could interact
with the data and then the second
question related to can I basically run
these analysis plans myself mimicking
what we've done into the land and then
downloading the data out of land and
comparing and that kind of gets to that
the erased suite product line which is
basically paired with the land so the
land database and the tools for it are
allowing you to basically you know and
for yourself to visualize delete the
database in both from bioinformaticians
or biologists but we actually have an
array suite product which is primarily
geared with informatician which would
let you store manage and then run
analysis pipelines yourself on both the
NGS and omics data
dr. Williams thank you very much for
your presentation today and your
important research I'd also like to
thank our sponsor Kaia giin for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
2018 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know that this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now and thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon bye bye